[Music]
in anything for love news sounds very
romantic submitted by hello from Houston
pen yeah
whose dog a woman was arrested after
pretending to be a deputy to get her
boyfriend out of jail oh yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah she got so I feel like she would do
that for me for me we got Tiger now I
got to think about some stuff oh my god
I gotta think about it
she had this fight mm-hmm
I wasn't listening to what he was saying
I was trying to picture what how the
girl did it cells lost in my own head
and then the question Katie realign like
it's quiet I'm like all [ __ ] you're
lying did I think she would help but not
in like a stupid way she'd figure it out
everyone's trying to help you right now
Gio of course I would do it all right so
this story is about vaccine who's 30
years old and her 23 year old boyfriend
named Nicholas that's why she 30 that's
already the problemos right there
why is it so happy to be arrested who's
23 the kid is 23 Trudy how is he so
happy why do they look like the same age
he's in jail right I thought she was why
does she the younger one that looks like
a mugshot from her not him he looks like
that looks like a facebook headshot yeah
that's like his key cards go in yeah
they got the same background - that's
his kindergarten uh hiding in that mug I
know he's at work dude this is work he
looks like he makes a mean cup of coffee
at your local coffee shop little flower
cappuccino that writes the chalk sign
out some berries
what's the coffee of the day sir don't
buy me drawers teddy bears in the
[ __ ] milk phone alright so it takes
place in Arkansas by the way that's a
third problem right there 30:23 Arkansas
name one thing of Arkansas [ __ ] corn
you get here [ __ ] no no [ __ ] no clip we
came from Arkansas ya know oh yeah
there's things that you forget that even
exist Vermont NAT New Hampshire from New
Hampshire Vermont's got Ben and Jerry's
you know that's always right here and
they got maple syrup anyone know and
that's where people from New York go to
have better breakfast that we yeah New
Hampshire Vermont oh really
all of New England is just like one big
area though to me yeah you can get
everywhere like it out yeah so the
reason why I Maxine was arrested it was
because she was arrested on suspicion of
possessing a controlled substance with
intent to deliver I don't know what it
was what is controlled substance dragged
so much drags drags drugs Oh drugs I was
confused yeah why is it a controlled and
not a uncontrolled do you get under it's
just a substance we're done control just
be like tobacco yeah so it's controlled
by the government like you can't it's
restricted I was the literal translation
of controlled as in like you know like
it's under control yeah you're
controlling heroin control the boyfriend
Nicklas he had a hold from the Ventura
County Sheriff's Office in California I
was right there boss impersonation so
that's why he was arrested we both loved
doing this they just like to roleplay
they but initially both got arrested
okay okay then Maxine she was able to to
bond out the next day
but Nicholas couldn't because of that
hold so he had to be extradited
extradited from California to Arkansas
so the other way our results Oh
that's when Nicholas told his girlfriend
to pretend to be a deputy from the
Ventura County I wish I could hear that
conversation when I get a call costume
at Party City we will do this he'll be
funny if she couldn't even get like the
real ones so she got the sexy cop one
she just hops in the car so she driving
him to California
I wish the story was like that's way
more fun the midriff showing but no so
what ended up happening was when when
she was visiting him in jail he told her
to tell Washington County Detention
Center that Ventura County is having
issues with overcrowding and all low
priority extra extradition has been
suspended
how much trouble has this full gun and
to know all the she's 23
well that hold was for false
impersonation so this was shut down he's
fake being a barista
that's his barista costume hooking
master a master of disguise he's not
even 23 dude I know he even faked his
hey that's when the girl she called the
Arkansas Detention Center posed as a
California deputy and told them what she
told her to say and then she also
submitted some paperwork oh ma they do a
lot of work yeah smart breakout yeah so
then that's when they released him
shortly after receiving the for [ __ ]
maybe there's a problem with their
system here until two days later that's
when they got a call from the real
Ventura County deputy saying that he was
two hours away from picking him up
that's when they discovered that that
was fake so they both got out though
people got out Wow
they don't say how but they do mention
that they were captured and booked into
jail again and that now how can they pin
it on her though like are they like we
know you called like phone records
well camera cuz she came to pick him up
right no she was she didn't physically
bishi wrote everything oh wow we really
underestimated these two holy crap
that story you guys painted is way
funnier but the real one they did it
pretty smart why do they just go
straight to Mexico like how do they get
caught I'm almost rooting for these guys
- you're so dope they almost deserve it
at this point now that I got caught I
was really curious - but they are now so
maxine is now facing several charges
including forgery and criminal improves
impersonation and Nicolas is facing is
facing a second-degree escape charge
yeah that's a cool charge I hope they
get out I really did the cool charge
where are they California locals and
they were hiding in Arkansas they won't
tell me that so they did the crime in
California first he did he did but she
had drugs in Arkansas yes
oh and he got caught with those drugs
Kathy just stay out of trouble I think
that's the issue when you were coming in
and now I mean that's their job so it's
kind of hard not to stayin out of
trouble just looks like the local like
social media marketing guide for
Facebook you know like you going to him
he has like toys on his [ __ ] table
and [ __ ] it works for like a brand deal
company he rents those little scooter
seat that's why it's easy for him to be
fake and personate like impersonating
all these people yeah cuz you'd like oh
he's a barista
he's a hipster works at t-mobile he's a
social media consultant she kind of
looks like a criminal there she does she
was another eyebrows though she wouldn't
make up yeah yeah yeah right now she
looks like she just did some meth and
went to Walmart no she looks like a
schoolteacher that does a little bit she
looks like she breathes hard [ __ ]
nose breather Oh [ __ ] breathing hard
like if you fell asleep next don't you
play [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up just like
the world's most pleasant guy look at
him PETA
like we could be friends so she looks
like a thug but he looks like my
neighborhood coffee barista she's 30
right she's older hard ass breathing
[ __ ] now we're on the roasts he says
okay the roasting hassles up yeah one
portion of that
when people outsmart the system and they
do a good job I just want to give him a
pass me too as long as they didn't do
any violent crimes
yeah they got in trouble for what
impersonation we don't know why he's in
trouble and but they were charged with
impersonation or false impersonation was
first for him and now again for her so
I'm just wondering what that crime is
like like are you identity fee VIN like
what are you doing right because I mean
that means actors should just go to jail
too because they're just false be
impersonating Louis he's in jail
impersonating them back to the 1600s and
[ __ ] yeah what makes you think you're
Kermit the Frog imagine that'd be cool
Time Machine extradition yeah we gotta
[ __ ] lock you up in the [ __ ] with
those wooden jail cells be Abraham
Lincoln oh yeah is she the down ass
[ __ ] I got she's got him out I just
think it's so funny that we
underestimated this should all these
people like we were doing some stupidest
[ __ ] in our head that's how dumb we are
now we're the dumb ones is that the best
thing we came up with last compliment I
give Gio ever but that's probably how
geo get you out bro this way yeah we'll
take a smart way like a smarter you
should you're like a lawyer s way yes
you do a lawyer s way Thanks yeah cuz it
follows like ah [ __ ] my friends in jail
all right let me get a dump truck and
[ __ ] [ __ ] and like go through the
frickin gate yeah let's take it yeah
I'll bring him a spoon and then he'll
dig his way out and then I'll pick him
up and then I'll pick him up yeah like
from a year from now a year from now
I'll pick you up bro exactly what she
would do her people with the spoon no
now the spoon but digging tunnels
probably what is the easiest way you
think to break out of prison
cuz it still happens for a guy or girl I
think it I think it matters why what
what would a girl feel like girls can
just dues ya guys seduce the guards - oh
I forget that there's no guards mother
no orange is the new black happens
although a guy seduced his way out of
jail no girl seduced a guy I'll seduce
that dude dude the dealer is B so horny
walking the hallways at 3:00 a.m. well
to see the same person every day like 40
hours a week I grew up I grew mom dude
what do you grow accidentally slip a
nipple here and there no no no I just
beat shell like I'd come off really
[ __ ] normal build a really relation
of good relationship with them to where
they trust me and then we'd like fall in
love and then you just gotta have your
way so you have them drive you away yeah
we're in line you go to bar and then
Bart kills them yeah doesn't Oh
then you go back to jail because you
just commit murder okay let me think
about this wait wait wait she's has to
go back to do she escaped tale oh this
way it's so good never heard I'm sure
murders not that bad oh yeah we're back
[Music]